meanwhile let's shed some light on the
Democrats glaring hypocrisy and accusing
Republicans of undermining the Muller
investigation that I just alluded to now
you recall Democrats did everything they
could to undermine ken starr's
whitewater investigation into misdeeds
by President Clinton and you compare
what Democrats are saying now with what
they said back then there is a growing
concern I can tell you in the Senate in
the sense that mr. Starr is now
operating out of any sense of reasonable
behavior we get a politically motivated
prosecutor who is allied with the
right-wing opponents of my husband who
has literally spent four years looking
at every telephone million dollars yet
more than that now but looking at every
telephone call we've made every check
we've ever written this is a president
who on many issues is basically beyond
shame at this point so any sense of
fairness or thoroughness for the sake of
the investigation I think is
questionable from the White House he is
trying to distract and discredit to
distract attention from the Russian
investigation and to discredit whatever
a Muller says in the end I love that
let's go to the man who was in the eye
of the storm back then former
Independent Counsel Ken Starr joins us
from Washington and Harvard Law
Professor Emeritus Alan Dershowitz
is in Miami now guys before we get into
the Russia probe I need to get your
thoughts on this uproar over the staff
secretary Rob Porter he's now accused by
a couple of ex-wives of abusive behavior
and this was an absolute firestorm in
the White House briefing room today
professor Dershowitz your reaction to
the pretty quick takedown of Rob Porter
well I want to make a more general point
I think anybody who is accused by the me
two people or anybody else and who
denies it should have an opportunity to
make their case to present their
argument used to be that it was as she
said he said a dispute now it's a she
said
you can't even respond dispute both
sides have to be hurt a process has to
be put in place whether in the White
House in Congress anywhere else whether
it's a Republican like in this case or a
Democrat like Al Franken there has to be
an opportunity for both sides to present
evidence and there has to be a fair
process for determining who's telling
the truth sometimes it's obvious
sometimes it's clear but even in the
Bill Cosby case where it seems so
obvious to everybody the jury came back
with a hung jury so we need to have a
process we can't suspend due process
just because there's a movement afoot
that is making some very very important
points but we need due process judge
Starr now the move seems to be to take
down general Kelly because Kelly's
worked side by side with him and even as
one of his ex-wives said I don't want
him to lose its position in the White
House he's incredibly smart he's
incredibly dedicated to his job but I
personally had a you know they had a bad
relationship according to her but now
they're saying Kelly's got to go because
Kelly actually stood up for his
integrity because as Alan Dershowitz
said these were accusations and hadn't
seen a photo or anything like that I
guess right general Kelly I think was
waiting for the evidence and when the
evidence came in from what we know he
responded and he responded decisively
which we would expect of a good military
man and let me just add to what Alan
said and I agree with what he said we
need to be reminded in this country as
we were reminded by the Felix
Frankfurter
and many other justices and great jurors
that the history of Liberty in the
United States is largely the history of
procedure throwaway procedure through a
way to process and you have a very
different kind of state you do not have
a rule of law system it is precious and
so rushes to judgment are to be avoided
so let's get the evidence and evaluate
assess the evidence I think from what we
know that's what general Kelley was
doing now and let's move on from that
injury so what's happening today to
what's happening today in the Russian
investigation professor Dershowitz we
now know that the Clintons
paid for that dossier we now looks net
like now Sydney Blumenthal was involved
an old an old Clinton hand I'm a judge
dart knows about him very well was
funneling information to Christopher
Steele as well some of it looks like it
ended up in that dossier or second
dossier that ended up funneling in
perhaps in some way shape or form to
that FISA judge and yet Democrats will
say well that that's not dispositive
that the search warrant to follow the
Carter page was not only based in part
on that dossier so you can't throw the
baby out with the bathwater well we
don't know what the men's FISA Court
decided how much weight they gave
anything we don't know how much weight
was given by the FISA Court to any
particular aspect what we do know is
that people who file an application ex
parte in front of a court have a special
obligation to present all sides and to
make sure that if they're relying on
something and they know there are
questions about its credibility because
of its source they have an obligation to
prevent it fulsomely to the court now
there's a footnote apparently in the
application that does say that it came
from a partisan source that's not good
enough you need to present you need to
act as if the defense is presenting
their side because you have an
obligation to present both sides of the
issue and again as Ken said it's all
about process process is the way in
which we achieve fairness and I think
there were real problems with the
process here and when you see the
Democratic memo I want to hear both
sides of the issue but at the moment I
think there was a breakdown of process
judge Starr as a former federal
appellate court judge you think about
this this FISA judge we don't know who
it is I guess there were a number of
judges involved in reviewing these
applications if a material fact had been
withheld in that application to spy in
an American citizen and a material fact
is the opposition candidate paid for the
dossier among other things does is there
any recourse for the judge at this point
is there sanctions that can be filed
against certain Justice Department
attorneys I mean we had Joe digenova on
the
the other night judge who said he
thought there could be ethical issues
for the FBI and maybe even criminal
charges if indeed there was some type of
conspiracy to keep this information
well it's serious let's not rush to
judgment let's be consistent and say we
need to know how that FISA application
for the renewal was in fact prepared who
prepared it what did they know when do
they know it and so I do think that this
is a very serious issue for the reasons
that Alan stated and there's another
dimension this the FISA regime was
designed to provide a judicial check on
what might otherwise be untrammeled
executive excess potential abuses and so
there is a very special if I do should
call it a fiduciary relationship that I
think is very deep probably as deep as
it gets there always should be honesty
and transparency with the court there's
no excuse for anything short of that but
it's all the more sensitive when you're
talking about the power of the executive
branch to spy to spy on Americans that
can read your emails there's one more
soundbite I want to play for you guys
professor Dershowitz this was Eric
Holder former attorney general speaking
out today let's watch if one looks at
the dismissal of James Comey and the
reasons why the president told
westerholt he did that if you look at
the president's attempts to try to get
people who were the heads of the
intelligence agencies to get involved in
this matter if you look at the
president's actions on the airplane with
regard to that statement there are a
variety of other things I think you
technically have a case of obstruction
of justice
president Dershowitz your reaction to
that very quickly well I think he's
wrong President George Bush the first
did practically the same thing when it
came to iran-contra he pardoned the
caspar weinberger and a handful of other
witnesses who could have pointed the
finger at him nobody suggested
obstruction of justice a president can't
obstruct justice in my view if he simply
exercises this constitutional authority
he has to do something like suborn
perjury destroy evidence pay hush money
the way Nixon did
well next Eric Holder has an interesting
way of looking at these facts but I knew
dersh we get it right as usual
the dynamic duo you guys fantastic thank
you so much and by the way it's ironic
don't you think how the Democrats keep
peddling this false story of trumps
collusion with Russia